if you've ever struggled at the end of
the month and worked all the way there
to only to look at the bank account and
find that there was nothing there
there was too little for you to take out
and then been like i literally just
worked for an entire month for nothing
then this video is for you all right so
one of the number one issues that i see
when i talk to small business owners of
ms
or medium-sized business owners is that
they don't have an adequate grasp on the
difference between gross
and net margin and the reason i'm
coloring the background green and i'm
using my green pen
is that margin is about the money so um
this is a topic
that people do not talk about it is also
probably the number one thing that i
look at in a business to determine its
health
and whether i would be interested in
investing or any of those types of
things
so let me break down the difference
between gross margin and net margin and
then i'm going to tell you the
functional ways
that i use to fix a business alright so
gross margin
gross margin is what the
direct cost of fulfilling your goods or
services are and so the equation for it
don't get everyone's like i don't like
math it's subtraction all right
it's not math that you be you're
confused about if you like zone out at
this moment
it's because you don't want to do the
thinking to understand the words
i want to be really clear i'm literally
going to use subtraction here all right
it's the revenue how much money you're
making minus
the cost of goods sold all right that's
the cogs now
the thing is if you're in a service
business your cost of goods sold isn't
the physical products that you're
selling because you're not selling those
you're selling people you're selling
payroll hours all right
and so the cost of goods sold for a
service business which is what the
majority of people are listening to this
are using
is the incremental cost of the
additional unit
which means that that doesn't count your
front desk roll that doesn't count your
hr director it doesn't count
your rent none of that stuff counts it's
just the cost
of one additional unit all right very
important
your net margin and i'm going to give
you examples in a second
your net margin is your chop
right that's what it's the juice at the
end of the month it's what you get
after everything is paid what's left
over that's what you end up taking home
all right but the gross margin in my
opinion well they're both obviously very
important
but the gross margin is the one that
begets that creates the net margin
and this is the one where i always focus
and this is the thing that i fix and
this is what i
help people fix and this is the game all
right so
my revenue minus cost so let's say we're
selling a service
for 60 per per
you know per hour that's what that's
what let's just say you know you're a
hair stylist or your trainer doesn't
matter right
you're selling 60 right in your business
and your cost of goods sold let's say is
20 bucks right
you're paying somebody 20 for the 60
thing you're like that sounds good
there's 40
left over for me this makes sense right
wrong all right and i'll get to why in a
second and what number i use
um but let's just do this so you can
understand what the gross margin is here
so the gross margin on this and that's
assuming we're not using any product
to like work on this if you were like a
hair stylist for example but let's just
say simply here
60 is what you're charging 20 is what it
costs
and 40 is left over right now what you
do to figure out your margins you take
that 40
right what's left over divided by the 60
of revenue which is what you got gross
and what that does is it gets 66 percent
that's the gross margin you'll be like
oh that that sounds reasonable that's
not
that much you know that's not that bad
the thing is is each
incremental gross margin point is
enormous
and so let me show you the difference so
let's say at the end of the year you're
running a business that runs on 66
gross margins and let's say at the very
end of the year now we're in the net
margin category
you uh you end up with 12 margins all
right now most brick and mortar
businesses run
around there crazy right but that's what
most brick and mortar businesses run
around
so if you're at 12 margins and i say
listen you got to be at 80
people like well 80 and 66 it's not that
different if you bumped your margins to
80 percent
what happens at the end of the year
that's 14 all right so what that
does is you now have 26
net margins at the year we more than
doubled we 2.2 x
how much you make so do you think this
is important
can i double how much you make simply by
changing this one number
yes all right so let's use the 80
example which by the way
is my rule of thumb this is the number
that i get any service based business
over all right doesn't matter what
you're selling this is what you have to
get over
all right now i'll show you the
difference between 80 90 95 100 in a
second but this is important
all right so if 80
uh gross margin is what i need there's
two ways i can do it
one i can decrease this cost
right i could say that i get this to 12
12 right this becomes 12 bucks so cross
that out
and now my uh my new uh take home
on this is 48 dollars right
and so 48 dollars
over 60 equals 80
so one way you can increase your margin
is decreasing your cost gross margin the
cost of actually doing the thing
right the second way is by increasing
how much you charge
this guy right and so let's say instead
of 60
and we have this 20 so what is
how do we get 80 loafed over if we have
a 20 cost
well it's easy with this number because
20 is 20 right
and so that means that you'd have to
charge a hundred dollars
for your 20 thing to have
an 80 margin and so way number one
you decrease the cost of fulfilling the
thing way number two you increase the
price
right now this is why this is so
important
obviously i showed you at the end of the
year you'd have a lot of money but
besides that if you're making a hundred
dollar
or you're charging a hundred dollars or
something right and it cost you 20
you got 80 left over all right now from
that 80
and here's what's important you have to
pay for everything else in the business
and have enough money to market to
acquire more customers
and you have to have enough money
uh uh to have a profit right and so it
seems like you're like eighty percent
alex that's crazy
and so by the way all successful
businesses the biggest businesses in the
world
they're not running 80 margins they're
running 99
gross margins all right and you're like
well they're only that's only 19
more it's actually not it's so much more
than that so let me break down this
difference real quick and then i'll
finish this example so the difference
between 80
margins 90 margins
95 margins right
uh i'll just go all the way to 100 right
and 100 let's do this
is that difference between 80 and 90 is
that this is twice
as profitable as this why because it's
half the cost
right it means i took that 20 and made
it 10 right
that's the difference you're looking at
this side of the equation not all of
this
all right this is between 90 and 95
gross margins
again twice as profitable and what i
mean by that is that
you can sell twice as many people for
the same cost
that is the magic and that is how you
scale that is how you get something
that's enormously profitable allows you
to acquire customers
and has tons of profit kicking off every
single month
and so this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs get messed up because they
feel
bad about charging a lot for their
services or a lot for their products or
whatever
right the thing is is that if you do not
do this you will make no profit and you
will not be able to scale you will not
help more people
unless you get this price you got to get
over this mental barrier that you have
around what you're able to charge for
things that don't cost you a lot of
money
right right okay so back to this example
so if i have 80 left over
that means that it depends on what my
cost of acquisition is so let's say
uh you know there's a certain percentage
of my revenue that i'm willing to give
for cost of acquisition
let's say it's 20 right so if 20 of this
i'm willing to give
uh that means that 16 is what i have
left
to market this right because you see
like you can only use it off of what's
left here and you still
after you pay your marketing right
you still have the rest of your costs
you still have rent you still have
payroll you still have you know a
payroll for all the non-essential stuff
you still have
software stuff all these other costs of
doing business
all right that have to come out of just
the remainder between here
and here all right this is the game and
so
in in sum total here if i'm looking at a
business
the big number that i'm looking at is 80
and that's what i i target i target any
business
especially for service that's over 80
and so if i'm trying to invest in
something i'm trying like this is the
game
that we get to and so you can do this
for any brick and mortar business for
your business for anything
you got to be over 80. and ideally
pushing from 80 to 90 or 90 to 95 at
each of these increments
doubles the productivity of the business
again
right and that's where it gets magical
and so the two ways you can do it
just as a quick recap to increase your
gross margin is number one
you can decrease the cost
and number two you can increase the
price
and that is how you can increase your
gross margin percentage
all right so i hope that was i before
you hope that made sense i hope if you
look at your own services and you're
like
well like what's my gross margin break
it down what's the additional cost
for one more person right um if i like i
said earlier if i was selling something
for 60
and if you don't know let's say you've
got one person i'll give you one more
example for this
let's say you've got the type of
business
where one person fulfills for many
people because you're like i don't know
what my cost would be
so i actually had this example not that
long ago i was at a mastermind
and a guy said he's got coaches and they
coach people right and so
i said well what are you know what are
your gross margins he's like i have no
idea i was like well let's walk through
it together
so he was paying his coach four thousand
dollars a month all right
that's what he was paying his coach and
i said cool
how many clients can your coach handle
he said well
um my my coach can handle uh 40 people
all right 40 clients i was like okay
what do you charge your clients per
month he said well i sell packages and i
was like all right
what are your packages costing it's like
they're 1200 packages i was like okay
what does 1200
get me he said it gets you three months
i'm going to give you a real world
example here so please you dice dig this
all right
which means that it's 400 per month if
you spread it out
right so he's got 40 clients
400 a month is what is what they're what
they're charging
all right which means 40 times 400
hopefully my math is right here is 160
000 hopefully
am i missing something up here i think
it's 160 000 isn't it
uh zero four times four thousand sixteen
thousand
i was like whoa um is sixteen thousand
dollars
per month right that's cool
right that's neat so sixteen thousand
dollars per month and the cost of the
coach is four thousand
right everyone following with me so it
means that there's twelve thousand left
over
so that's what's left over after the
cost and then we're just dividing it by
the total
revenue right which is this guy you just
bring it back down so it's just 12
divided by 16
right which in this instance would be 75
so he's close to 80 but he's like well
you know i don't want to change anything
because
because i'm already at 75 but remember
at the end of the year
the end of the year let's say you've
you've got 15
margins right let's just say at the end
of the year you got 15 percent bumping
the extra five
takes you to 20 right you're like oh wow
that doesn't seem like a big difference
15 to 20 net margins at the end of the
year is a
25
increase in how much money you make that
is how important this is
and so anyways so what would he need to
do he either has to pay this guy less or
he's got to charge
charge more money here and so um the way
to figure this out backwards if you
wanted to
if you didn't want to change excuse me
if you did want to change
your uh your price to get it over 80
then you simply
uh basically increase what this number
needs to be until it's 80
so um gosh what's the it's 1.6 times 8
whatever that is uh eight
and then uh uh god
it's uh 12.8 yeah so that would mean
that he have to get to 12
800 if he wanted to get over 80
which means he either needs to charge
the the extra uh
40 clients an extra uh 200
no 20 yeah you need to charge an extra
20 bucks here
right per month or he could pay this
coach
3 200 per month and that is how he would
get
from 75 to 80
and that my friends is the game so
hope you found this useful hopefully you
like this hopefully you thought this was
awesome
if you didn't um well please tell me i
just want to make stuff that you guys
find valuable this is the game this is
the stuff that i dive super deep into
when i'm trying to fix a business model
uh or i'm consulting with somebody and i
hope you find that valuable too so
anyways keeping awesome please leave a
post or review or any of that good stuff
and i will see you on the next one bye